I isn't DC kind of retired no these he
wants to fight Brock he's gonna fight
Brock and he's gonna retire he's gonna
just kind of get that to me to me the
most the most impressive fighter to ever
step in the Octagon is Daniel Cormier
you certainly won a fight but I'm just
an intern causing more impressive when
when John Jones beat him because well so
John Jones is without a doubt the most
talented and best fighter to me with the
tools that DC is working with when
you're five-nine five-ten and you you
know you just you're dealing with guys
with so much taller with so much more
regional he's undefeated as a
heavyweight the only man he's ever lost
to was John Jones and everybody else all
comers
see Pam you know she just give me a
number yeah and he take heat he's taking
everyone I'm out listen almost giant
fans just incredible don't get me wrong
it just shows you how good John Jones
mr. John Jones has his number whatever
the case but it's both you know I'd like
to see DC fight John Jones at
heavyweight me to 240 that might happen
that might be the big fight the big
fight might be if DC fights Brock let's
assume he beats Brock which I think he
would then DC fights John Jones yeah but
he might not be Brock here's the thing
about Brock and this is so ridiculous to
say he's still a [ __ ] giant Viking
human yeah he's so extraordinarily big
he's so powerful that if he clips DC
anything can happen
yeah but he's got a he's gonna get
punched in the face by DC and I think I
personally believe that if you are not
getting punched in the face and working
on patterns and really working on your
striking you get into the ring with a
guy like Daniel Cormier who does that
every day true but we don't know the
rats in the jaw we don't we don't know
that that's the case we also know that
he has been wrestling with this michigan
state wrestler that's one of the best
wrestlers on the planet Earth this video
of him wrestling with this current
phenom yeah and he's training with like
real elite world-class fighters but
you're striking yeah but Daniel Cormier
got that yeah down and he's also Brock
is also the WWE champ bro there is that
strong people around there
is that got hit with a chair you're
right I don't know man I mean all my
money on DC I would say that DC would be
heavily favored yeah I would also say
that that big gorilla can [ __ ] punch
any person on the planet with those
lunch box vist s-- and you're [ __ ]
he's so big man when you stand next to
brock you just like oh you're a totally
he's having fun silverback yeah he's
this close to a silverback because i've
ever seen so viking man yeah you know so
long arms giant human yeah ridiculous
fists the real question is i mean how
much has he really been working on his
striking in in these years that he's
been outside of the cage how much does
he much easier to work on your wrestling
if you're him striking is a whole
different animal well particularly
sparring not just like hitting mitts and
hitting the pad but getting getting good
rounds and against people that can crack
and people that can crack like DC where
he clinches you and then hits you in the
clinch and also learning how to adjust
like the great fighters that i noticed
our guys who they come in with a game
plan that game plan gets shut down and
then they change it up right then they
do subtle things they just start doing
little differences and you go oh you're
you're doing a you're doing a whole
different thing here yeah and that guy
can't see it or a lot of people can't
and that's what i think it's amazing
then there's the other thing he's got to
get off the sauce yeah he got off the
sauce so if he gets off the sauce now
he's 40 and he's been on Mexican
supplements for the last few years for
sure yeah and your whole endocrine
system is just like where's my rhoids
good luck yeah yeah I mean yes who knows
who know